- [Instructor] There are
170 deer on a reservation.
The deer population is increasing
at a rate of 30% per year.
Write a function that gives
the deer population P of t
on the reservation t years from now.
All right, let's think about this.
And like always, pause this video,
and see if you can work
it out on your own.
Well, let's think about what P of zero is.
P of zero, this is going to be
the initial population of deer,
the population at time zero.
Well, we know that, that's
going to be the 170 deer
that we start on the reservation.
Now, let's think about what P of one is.
What's going to be the
population after one year?
Well, it's going to be our
original population, 170,
but then it increases at
a rate of 30% per year.
So it's going to be 170
plus another 30% of 170.
So I could write that as 30% times 170.
Or I could write this as 170
plus 0.3
times 170.
30% as a decimal is the same
thing as 30/100 or 3/10.
Or I could write this as,
if I factor out 170,
I would get 170
times
one plus
0.3, which is the same thing as 170
times 1.03.
And this is a really good
thing to take a hard look at
'cause you'll see it a lot
when we're growing by a certain rate,
when we're dealing with
what turns out to be
exponential functions.
If we are growing,
well, I almost made a
mistake there, it's 1.3.
So here you go, 1.3.
One plus 0.3 is 1.3.
So once again, take a hard
look at this right over here
because it's going to be something
that you see a lot with
exponential functions.
When you grow by 30%,
that means you keep your
100% that you had before,
and then you add another 30%.
And so you would multiply your
original quantity by 130%,
and 130% is the same thing as 1.3.
So if you are growing by 30%,
you are growing by 3/10,
you would multiply your
initial quantity by 1.3.
So let's use that idea to keep going.
So what is the population after two years?
Well, you would start that second year
with the population at
the end of one year.
So it's going to be that 170
times 1.3.
And then, over that year,
you're going to grow
by another 30%.
So if you're gonna grow by another 30%,
that's equivalent to
multiplying by 1.3 again.
Or you could say that this
is equal to 170 times 1.3
to the second power.
And so I think you see
where this is going.
If we wanted to write a general P of t,
so if we just want to
write a general P of t,
it's going to be whatever
we started with, 170,
and we're going to multiply that by 1.3
however many times, however
many years have gone by.
So to the t power
because, for every year, we grow by 30%,
which is equivalent mathematically
to multiplying by 1.3.
So after 100 years,
it would be 170 times
1.3 to the 100th power.